dear oddball fantasize er outsider
daydreamer the protester dear rebel you
matter full stop but you already knew
that
well because 2018 was a year for us
misfits
the new COO the nonconformist therefore
this isn't about you yes - you the one
deemed and creative paper-pusher
predictable stereotypes conventional the
New Age black sheep this was me eight
years ago far too scared about what
people thought of me to even talk to the
camera this is me eight years later
transitioned from a follower to a
collaborator a watcher to a maker a lone
wanderer two wandering together and I
owe it to you brute so I made you a card
a card for the holidays it's not a
religious card or linked to anything
spiritual other than the story brew brew
black sheep once upon a time in a small
seaside town brew was born and to a
scrappy bushy-tailed border collie named
woof took its first yarn the two of them
lived in the confines of one simple hood
- never venture to the land beyond the
rail labor wolf a leader by default and
brew and outsider from birth grew apart
quickly as wolf didn't see Bruges worth
you see wolf didn't ever obey the simple
code until one morning after venturing
out he never showed brew who patiently
grew wiser over the years finally was
equipped enough to face new frontiers
wolf however wasn't as patient and had
peaked too early brew walks past wolf's
old art piece and things that can't be
me
surely brew shots wolf you there an
outer dark corner crawls wolf filled
with despair but brew holds no
resentment and gets wolf ride back on
his feet by negotiating in my house just
down the street
whoo rich and life-experience fearless
and with great esteem along with brew
diligent consistent giving make the
perfect team they both end up
flourishing two youngsters from humble
chromakey you knew you see the story
that I'm telling is true I was there
playing the role of wolf and Lisa my
beautiful twin sister brew is you this
card was written to the person in my
life that hasn't received - thank you
she deserves from me behind me here is
chroma key that's where Lisa and I grew
up and on this side of the train tracks
is Cape Town we both live in big cities
now and Lisa is a lawyer and I'm a film
director and youtuber as I look back on
the past 20 whatever years of my life I
want to pay tribute to the legends to
everybody who doesn't get the
celebration they deserve on the media
you never hear about the ones that make
the world spin the ones that make it
possible for creative nomads to turn
their passion into a paid job the one
saving lives from behind desks the ones
keeping the engine roiled yes to
everybody who quietly achieves greatness
without any form of external affirmation
this is a car dedicated to every single
person that hasn't received the praise
they deserve this year you are brewed in
the story you're awesome and I hope you
have the most fantastic holiday this
card is reusable and holds equal
sentiment when you pass it on so please
pass it on to your loved ones other than
that don't forget to like subscribe and
comment on the video let me know your
thoughts see you next week Wednesday
[Music]